devops is a collaborative approach just
taken up by most companies these days it
focuses on scaling up and making the
entire process of scaling up much
smoother so no doubt companies are
actively looking out for devops
engineers welcome to another tutorial
with simply learn i'm anjali and today
we'll be looking into how you can become
a devops engineer so let's begin so by
definition devops is a collaboration
between the development and the
operations team which enables continuous
delivery of application and services to
the end users so let's expand on this
definition first the development team is
the one that actually produces the
products the operation team is related
with the management or the maintenance
of these products now there's a link
that devops forms between these two
teams which makes this entire process
much smoother and this approach this
collaborative approach is what's called
devops so devops focuses on continuous
delivery of application which means that
when the development team is ready with
the product it immediately goes into the
maintenance or the management phase and
it's then pushed on to the end users
with minimum delay just in case you
doubt the stand of devops today or its
growth in the near future you must know
that according to the information week
devops will be in high demand for
upcoming years and has no chance of
slowing down also according to linkedin
over the past few years devops has
increased in demand by 50 percent now
that's quite a lot of growth so clearly
devops is a field that will be great to
dive into and grow in so before we begin
how you can actually become a devops
engineer let's look at what we'll be
going through in this video first we
look at who is a devops engineer
followed by the devops career roadmap
we'll then look into a devops
certification and then finally the
salary trends for a devops engineer so
who is a devops engineer now a devops
engineer is an i.t professional who
understands the software development
lifecycle and when i say software
development cycle i did not just mean
the devops approach but right from a
waterfall model which is a traditional
software development life cycle and then
as you know we moved on to the agile and
finally we reached the devops life cycle
so a devops engineer needs to understand
the whole purpose of this life cycle why
we had to move from one model to the
other what are the shortcomings that the
previous models had and what all does
devops make up for also other than
understanding this entire process they
also need to know how to use the various
automation tools for developing the
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipelines so of course your
next question must be what is the
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipeline as you can see on
your right we have an image of this
pipeline so there are various stages so
first you have your planning stage where
you plan things out and write an
algorithm for your product then it's the
building stage where the algorithm
actually transforms into a code and is a
product which could be used then you
have the testing stage in the testing
stage your product is tested all the
bugs are caught and all of this is
corrected and once all of that's done
it's then sent to the deployment stage
which means now your product is ready to
be deployed once it's deployed of course
a product needs continuous monitoring
this is now something new which has been
introduced in the devops lifecycle that
although your product is out in d now
the monitoring stage is something that
the devops approach focuses on much more
than our previous models and for very
good reason which is that once your
product is deployed into the real world
to ensure customer satisfaction it's
important that you continuously monitor
the product this way you're able to
catch the bugs fix them and push it back
to the clients and ensure that they are
happy with your product and would go for
it again now in simple words a devops
engineer is expected to collaborate with
the developers and the operations team
to deliver high quality products within
a minimum amount of time now devops
engineer as such is not a profile that
you might come across very often but of
course there are number of career paths
that you can take under the devops
engineer but of course there are a
number of career paths under a devops
engineer some of these are the devops
architect automation engineer software
tester integration specialist security
engineer and release manager now let's
look at the devops career roadmap so
basically if you are looking forward to
bagging that devops engineer job where
should you start and how should you go
about it first thing first there are a
few programming languages which go hand
in hand with the devops tools you need
to pick up these and also know the linux
fundamentals devops uses these
programming languages for developing and
automating software now three most
common languages used with the devops
tools are ruby python and javascript it
is always advised that you know at least
one of these of course we must consider
the fact that these three languages are
used with completely different tools so
knowing just one of these languages does
not mean that you can now work with any
tool under the devops approach but it
does give you a good hang of at least
one of them which is more than most can
say it's also important to know the
fundamentals of the linux command line
interface of course this is not very
unique to devops whichever career path
you are choosing linux fundamentals is
one of the most important things let's
now discuss some of the mandatory linux
skills that a devops engineer should be
aware of the first is of course the
linux shell now you must either know
bash or the kernel shell then it's the
linux commands now there are a huge
number of linux commands but the basic
ones you must know no matter what are
the find grep awk and the set command
and finally we have the networking
commands nslookup which is for querying
the dns and netstat for monitoring your
connections our next milestone would be
learning the source code management now
source code management is especially
important when you're dealing with huge
projects so that all your code
irrespective of the number of files you
have or the number of versions of a
particular code you have everything is
organized and can be easily accessible
so it's important that you're
comfortable with at least one of the
source code management tools here the
most common ones we see are git cvs and
mercurial i would personally recommend
you to choose git and why git because
git is used to track changes in the
source code it can manage large projects
efficiently and it allows multiple
developers to work together with great
ease now our next stage is to learn to
build applications so a devops engineer
must know how to build an application
and commit to the source code management
tool such as kit now popular tool used
to build applications which makes things
much simpler is maven why maven well it
supports parallel builds instant access
to new features without any additional
configuration and has an easy build
process now maven is actually an
automation tool which helps to build and
manage software projects within a short
period of time so here you have the bom
file which is required to build an
application under which you have set of
jars you have the commands which are to
be executed the builds plugins and the
builds profile but in order to automate
the entire process you require a
continuous integration or a continuous
development tool and this brings us to
our fourth stage which is learning to
automate the process using ci and cd
tools one of the most extensively used
tools in this field is jenkins jenkins
is an open source continuous integration
tool it helps to automate continuous
development testing and deployment of
newly created codes well why jenkins
because it has multiple plugins it is
easily distributed across multiple
machines and has an easy installation
and configuration process our next stage
is to learn to test the applications
once you have completed the build
process learn how to automate the
testing process of web applications one
of the best testing tools for qa teams
is selenium and why selenium above all
the other tools that provide the same
functionality well because it provides
fast execution allows scripting in
several languages and also supports
parallel test execution the next thing
is to learn to deploy applications in
production servers so you should learn
how to deploy and run the applications
in the production servers and in order
to deploy an application you should have
the knowledge of containers such as
docker and configuration management
tools like ansible so docker helps with
the containerization while configuration
management tools such as ansible so
docker helps with containerization while
tools such as ansible helps you to
provide you the capability of pushing
configurations onto multiple servers and
maintaining them in the required state
so why choose docker high scalability
and efficiency reusable data volumes
isolated applications and why ansible
because unlike other tools in this field
it has a push based configuration it is
agentless and uses ssh for secure
connections the next stage is to learn
to monitor the applications so
monitoring your applications is another
important aspect of a devops engineer in
this stage we identify the issue and
implement the changes as quickly as
possible the most popular tool which
provides for monitoring applications is
nagios it has a comprehensive monitoring
system high availability and immediate
remediation and finally a devops
engineer must know the working of cloud
providers for a devops engineer it's
important to know about the cloud
service providers and their basics cloud
computing is an important skill to learn
irrespective of which field you're in
today as a lot of companies have the
infrastructure on the cloud amazon web
services is the most popular cloud
provider whereas microsoft azure and
google cloud platform are slowly
catching up to amazon amazon web
services provides high scalability and
flexibility is cost effective and
provides better security let's now look
at some of the devops certifications you
can opt for the first one is the aws
certified devops engineer program which
is offered by amazon web services and
then of course we have the devops
certification training offered by our
very own simply learn simply learn also
provides programs which are more
specific to tools such as chef puppet
ansible and selenium certification and
we also provide a devops architect
masters program so now these are some of
the most popular certifications
available in the market if you're taking
up a career you must know what kind of
salary to expect an average salary of a
devops engineer in the united states is
fifteen thousand six hundred and sixty
six dollars per year so this is the
average salary as you can see here guys
there's a graph which shows how there's
been a growth this graph here will give
you a good idea of the salary trend an
average salary of a devops engineer in
india on the other hand is 6 lakh 12 000
per year so again here we have a graph
on the right which demonstrates the
pattern in growth in the salary now
here's some additional material to
prepare yourself and help you in the
journey to becoming a devops engineer so
this is simply learnt's youtube playlist
on devops as you can see here are a
number of videos you can start off with
this fun short video on what is devops
it introduces devops to you in the most
basic and fun way possible and then you
have devops tutorial for beginners what
is devops another tutorial introduction
to devops and then you can follow this
up with the tutorials on the various
tools under devops for example there's
git there's jenkins docker docker swarm
ansible chef puppet a comparison between
the various configuration management
tools there are also devops interview
questions part one and part two which
will help you prepare for your
interviews why devops is better than
agile or if it's the other way around
watch this video to find out how to
create your resume for the post of a
devops engineer and so on so there are a
lot of videos here guys you can
definitely go through them provides you
with a lot of information not only that
before you actually take up the simply
learn course to get a better
understanding of the kind of content and
the quality of content that they offer
you can come here and check out their
free courses or their free tutorial
videos and with that we come to an end
of this video i hope you all enjoyed it
and i hope it was really helpful for all
those who are aspiring to become a
devops engineer please hit the like
button if so also share our video and
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
yet because we have a lot more coming up
for you so thank you and see you all
next time
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here